One of our country's founding principles was by the people,
for the people.
But it really has not been for the people for quite some time
in the last couple of years.
Most Americans live paycheck to paycheck
and anything extra
is just gonna break the backs of hard working Americans.
As a Christian, I am incredibly worried about this election.
A Harris administration
would mean a lot of negative things for the Christian community.
And this is why Christians cannot sit this election out.
As opting out as opting in to something.
This is why it is so important to vote.
More specifically voting early in person at your local county office.
Early voting
gives you the convenience of doing it on your own schedule
instead of on one specific day of the year
in case something would to rise or come up.
Also ensures that your vote is secure
and not gonna be tampered with in the mail
or lost in the mail or any of those types of things.
It helps reduce the stress on election pull workers
and helps you minimize human error.
Your vote matters in which direction this country is gonna go.
You cannot opt out this election.
So early voting helps you keep your vote secure and safe
and make sure it is counted. So get to the polls.